on this Tuesday night Canada's inflation
rate slides to a two-year low but it
doesn't mean much with the High Cost of
Living what seems to have been worse and
worse mounting questions about the bank
of Canada's strategy to cool inflation
Ontario's vow to improve its child
welfare system the proposed measures and
what's still missing
miscarriage of Justice in Manitoba
hopefully I can move on from here on the
life-changing decision two indigenous
men convicted of murder have waited 50
years for and Castaway oh I'm feeling
all right how this man and his dog
miraculously survived weeks lost at sea
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight far on that sir good
evening to you thank you for joining us
there is an encouraging sign about the
cost of living in Canada our annual
inflation rate fell again in June
putting it in the country's target range
for the first time in years but it's not
all good news
first the numbers inflation dropped to
2.8 percent down from 3.4 percent in May
and that's more than many analysts
expected in fact it's the lowest it has
been in more than two years and it marks
a substantial decline since its peak
last June at 8.1 percent lower gas
prices are the main driver pushing
inflation down but and there's a big one
the cost of groceries and mortgages are
up yet again sharply pushing the rate
even higher
just days ago the Bank of Canada hiked
interest rates for the 10th time in 16
months and many Canadians are still
struggling to afford the basics Korea
isri has our top story tonight
gas prices may be cheaper but with the
cost of living so high the savings may
not count for much I'm not too happy
about it but
the end of the day we're
doing what we can to get through I try
to work from home certain days just so
that I don't have to fill my tank like
every week the annual inflation rate
dipped below three percent last month
the lowest level in two years it's come
down significantly over the past year
but it's also largely reflecting the
impact of energy prices and how much
they've fallen over the past year food
prices have not Fallen they're up 9.1
percent from this time last year the
burden can feel even heavier for
Canadians struggling to pay the grocery
bill that's horse manure I'm sorry it's
more like 50 percent what seems to just
have been worse and worse every bag of
groceries seems to get higher and higher
last week the Bank of Canada announced
its 10th interest rate hike in just over
a year if we don't do enough now we'll
likely have to do even more later
raising it to five percent a 22-year
high all in an effort to tame stubborn
inflation but higher borrowing costs are
heard Canadians carrying debt and
homeowners with variable mortgages
what's a real problem for the bank here
now is that as you raise interest rates
of course the mortgage portion of home
ownership costs gets more and more
expensive mortgage interest costs have
increased 30 percent year over year
which is fueling inflation and concerns
the central bank's approach is having
the opposite effect but there are a lot
of questions around how the Bank of
Canada is conducting a monetary policy
whether it's diagnosis of inflation is
actually correct and whether interest
rates are the the right remedy the Bank
of Canada is adamant it will keep
raising interest rates until inflation
reaches 2 percent it plans to hit that
Target by 2025. signaling more tough
times between now and then pharah
Ottawa thank you for that Sharia and if
you're a tenant it comes as no surprise
that rent is expensive and a new report
from the Canadian Center for policy
alternative suggests the cost in every
province is far outpacing the rate of
minimum wage in Canada's biggest cities
like Toronto and Vancouver even two
minimum wage earners can't afford a
one-bedroom apartment without spending
more than a third of their income as
Shadow Shea Explains It All Points to
life getting harder for those already
struggling the most
anyone trying to find an apartment in a
big city knows it rents are getting more
expensive and finding a place to live
when you have a low income is not easy
that's why so many tenants end up living
in places that have very bad conditions
they know they see the moment they're
going to rent but they have no other
choice for those earning some of the
lowest wages renting an apartment and
having enough money for other Essentials
is getting Beyond reach take Toronto
Canada's largest city even to minimum
wage workers with their combined income
could not afford a one-bedroom unit
without spending more than 30 percent of
their income on rent the budget numbers
look even worse for renters involved in
a rent strike in Toronto we have over
800 tenants in just these two buildings
behind where we organize I don't know
anyone that pays less than 50 percent of
their income on rent in its new report
the Canadian Center for policy
Alternatives calculated how much someone
would need to earn to rent a two-bedroom
apartment in Vancouver someone would
need a minimum hourly wage of more than
42 dollars in Toronto more than forty
dollars an hour in Ottawa thirty two
dollars in Halifax twenty seven dollars
an hour the report shows three
communities in Quebec requiring the
lowest hourly wages to earn that
two-bedroom apartment if they're working
full-time they can't afford rent uh they
eventually are going to start looking to
move elsewhere and in the meantime one
Economist says this is required we need
additional uh Financial supports for
renters to allow them to keep paying the
bills it's finding a place to rent in
cities gets harder for those earning
minimum wages researchers say who is
going to stay behind to work on those
shops who is going to stay behind to
work in in the service industry shuttle
Shea Global News Toronto
way of breaking news out of BC where 7
400 Port workers have once again walked
off the job
people are already back on the picket
lines tonight the union says the
tentative agreement reached last week
won't protect jobs now or in the future
the main issue is their wages
Contracting outside work and automation
the failed deal included with the BC
Maritime employers Association calls a
considerable hike in wages and benefits
there are some temporary relief tonight
for dozens of homeless refugees who have
been sleeping on the streets of downtown
Toronto two churches are taking them in
and the federal government has pledged
more money for cities to help house
Asylum Seekers but Advocates say it's
just a temporary solution and that the
government needs to do more
I hope that they call us I hope they
want to hear from us about us I hope
that they want to understand what it's
really taking to take care of these
people and that they will do what's
right I am a Canadian I want to be a
proud Canadian again
staff from all three levels of
government met today to discuss the
issue immigration Minister Sean Fraser
announced more than 200 million dollars
has been approved for interim Housing
Solutions for refugees with nearly half
of that money expected to go to Toronto
for a year Global's investigative unit
has been exposing the concerning
treatment of children in Ontario's child
welfare system now the Doug Ford
government is pledging to crack down on
Foster Homes and group homes that
provide substandard care with tougher
penalties fines and increased oversight
our chief investigative correspondent
Carolyn Jarvis is at Queen's Park in
Toronto to break down the plan Carolyn
for in black and white the Ontario
government is acknowledging that it
continues to hear that kids in its child
welfare system are not receiving the
care they deserve so it's proposing new
amendments to its child welfare laws and
regulations with an aim to fix that this
comes after we brought forward repeated
serious concerns from whistleblowers and
workers inside the system as well as
youth who said they lived in run-down
homes without enough food they slept on
soiled mattresses and were forcibly
restrained by workers without
justification the Ford government's
solution is more required visits to kids
in care and enhance powers to provincial
inspectors to assure compliance orders
and fines let's talk about those fines
then Carolyn do we have any sense of
what they'll look like well not for
inspectors but if a court were to find a
foster care or group home company guilty
of an offense those could reach up to
250 thousand dollars and the province
wants to add a whole list of prohibited
practices that could face penalties I'll
share a handful of them but just let me
emphasize here these are all things that
we've heard and are reporting are
occurring in recent years in Ontario's
child welfare system so prohibited would
be depriving a child of their basic
needs including food clothing or bedding
using racist language abusing or
spitting on kids and using physical
restraints as punishment what's not
included is how the province plans to
uncover these offenses I think what
these regulations does is put in a bare
minimum standard yes you won't die you
will eat you will not experience
hopefully racial slurs but then we also
need to raise the bar on what it needs
what it means to care for for Children
and Youth when you outline those those
requirements I mean bare minimum is the
right word now you've been in touch over
the past 24 hours with several
Children's Aid societies to gauge their
reactions to these changes and what are
you hearing from them
well some are applauding The increased
oversight but the resounding course is
that this doesn't address the root
concern that Ontario families are not
getting the support they need to prevent
kids from coming into care in the first
place it's perpetuating the use of group
homes
and it's going to make some people feel
it's okay to keep on using them
when it's not these kids should be in
their own communities or at the very
least they should be in the in their
Community hubs
the government has now opened a feedback
period if the proposed changes are
passed they won't take effect until
January pharah Carol and Jarvis
incredible work you've done on this file
thank you that's Carolyn Jarvis at
Queen's Park in Toronto
to The Climate crisis now where millions
of people around the world continue to
struggle with extreme heat Europe's
Cerberus Heat Wave has gripped much of
the continent during Peak tourism season
with no end in sight
in the U.S Phoenix has seen temperatures
of 43 degrees or higher for 19 days in a
row now breaking the city's 49 year old
Heat record and in China the historic
caused this road to explode with a
motorcyclist narrowly avoiding the
crumbling concrete
as Redmond Shannon reports Beijing is
set to host talks between American and
Chinese diplomats where climate action
will be a key Focus
from Alpine mountain tops to the
outskirts of Athens wildfires taking
hold forcing residents of all shapes and
sizes to flee a brutal Heat Wave
spanning much of Europe replicated
across parts of the northern hemisphere
yes I thought last summer was hot but
this doesn't even compare says this
woman in Serbia
across the Adriatic Rome broke its
all-time temperature record hitting
41.8 degrees the forecast is for more
with very little respite after dark a
repeated High night time temperatures
are particularly dangerous for human
health because the body is unable to
recover from sustained heat half the
world away parts of China are baking to
a record 52 degrees recorded on Sunday
as other areas battle typhoons likely
intensified by the warming Planet U.S
climate Envoy John Kerry is in Beijing
for climate solution talks with China
of our two countries coming together and
working and showing the rest of the
world
the U.S and China are the world's two
largest greenhouse gas emitters but last
week Kerry said this about paying
reparations for historic emissions no
for a while under no circumstances very
good the conflict between past and
current emitters the old world and the
new is Central to tensions that have
held up progress at carp climate Summits
there has to be a point of compromise
between us and China both countries have
to play the compromise game as the
evidence across the globe mounts and
mounts so does the pressure on the
world's two superpowers to find more
common ground on the future of a shared
Planet Redmond Shannon Global News
London
writing a horrible wrong 50 years in the
making cutting up two indigenous men
wrongfully convicted of murder finally
have their names cleared
after nearly two weeks of protests a
blockade outside a Winnipeg landfill has
now been dismantled by police
the camp had indicated that they were
prepared to remove things for the city
to come in and clean things up and
that's what we did today this is long
from over this isn't done we need to put
pressure on the federal government
this premiere
is useless she's useless
and uh
we got to go above her
protesters have been occupying the road
in response to the province deciding not
to search for the remains of murdered
indigenous women at another landfill
police say there are no plans to remove
a small camp that remains on the side of
the road
two men from the pine mutang first
nation in Manitoba are feeling relief
and freedom tonight back in the 1970s an
all-white jury convicted Brian Anderson
and Alan Woodhouse of murdering a man in
Winnipeg last month the federal Justice
Minister ordered a new trial one that
Advocates say was rooted in systemic
racism Global smarney blunt was in the
courtroom today for the emotional
reaction that was decades in the making
cheers erupted outside a Winnipeg
Courthouse Tuesday as Brian Anderson and
Alan Woodhouse appeared outside for the
first time as innocent men half a
century later Woodhouse can only
describe their acquittal in one way well
I feel free Manitoba chief justice Glenn
joyal officially acquitted the pair
convicted of murder in the death of Ting
Fon Chan who was stabbed to death in
Winnipeg in 1973.
Justice joyal saying to the men in court
you deserve to hear two things very
clearly you are innocent and you deserve
the acquittal I'm happy to enter you
also deserve an apology words Anderson
and Woodhouse have been waiting five
decades to hear it's been a long time
coming so
um I'm glad that it's here already and
it's dealt with
so I'd like to
hopefully I can move on from here on and
the decision even drawing some emotion
from the lawyers to hear the uh the
judge say today to Mr Anderson and Mr
Woodhouse you are innocent I accept you
are innocent those are amazing words to
lawyers like us to hear a judge
directly state to two people who've been
fighting a battle for more than 50 years
it's absolutely amazing Woodhouse spent
17 years in prison and maintained his
innocence for decades Anderson spent 10
years in prison after entering into a
guilty plea that his lawyers said was
obtained through physical violence
intimidation and threats from police
it's a case that leaves deep wounds that
may never heal no I think I'm hurt too
much to be angry
I'm hurting more than 900. now in their
late 60s both men say they're ready to
move forward well life like you know I
need I I want to live too well it's
about time somebody believes me that
means 50 years a long time when asked
about potential compensation the lawyer
said that would be determined at a later
date and that innocence Canada will have
more to say on their next steps on
Wednesday adding that today is about
Anderson and Woodhouse finally having
their innocence recognized and that
hopefully they can begin the process of
replacing whatever anger they may have
with joy pharah
Marty blunt in Winnipeg thank you Marnie
[Music]
potential prosecution ahead why former
U.S president Donald Trump could be
facing another round of criminal charges
[Music]
in the U.S Michigan's attorney general
has charged 16 Republicans with multiple
felonies for their alleged role in his
scheme to overturn the 2020 election by
falsely claiming to be presidential
electors they're accused of citing
paperwork that said Donald Trump won
that state and now Trump himself says
he's on the verge of being indicted in a
third probe over the January 6th attack
on the U.S Capitol and as Jackson prosco
reports criminal charges against the
former president could be imminent
it was a violent attempt to keep a
defeated president in power
all right
for the first time Donald Trump is
staring down the prospect of criminal
charges for his alleged schemes to
overturn the election he lost from a
slate of fake electors to the attack on
January 6th we will never give up we
will never concede it doesn't happen you
don't concede with his theft Trump says
he received a Target letter from special
counsel Jack Smith indicating he's a
focus of the investigation he's invited
to appear before a grand jury a sign
he's likely to be indicted I think he's
going to say look the cake is baked at
this point the special counsel is going
to bring charges there's no point in my
testifying before a grand jury all it
could do is potentially lead to a
perjury charge potential charges could
include conspiracy to defraud the United
States and obstruction of an official
proceeding despite his impeachment a
congressional investigation and
seditious conspiracy convictions against
January 6th rioters Trump continues to
claim it's all political they want to
interfere with the election but his
legal troubles Run Deep Trump already
faces 37 federal charges brought by the
special counsel over the highly
classified documents recovered from his
Florida home a court hearing Tuesday
began work to set a date for Trump's
looming prosecution in that matter if a
grand jury votes to indict Trump over
January 6 the charges will likely be
brought here at a courthouse just steps
away from the berry Capitol building
that came under siege and unlike in
Florida a jury here in Washington is
less likely to be sympathetic to the
former president
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
a rescued
now to a remarkable Story of Survival
that played out on the Pacific Ocean an
Australian sailor and his dog are safely
back on land tonight after being lost at
sea for weeks where they battled
exhaustion Despair and hunger Mike
Armstrong has the details behind this
made for Hollywood journey and Rescue
It was supposed to be a bucket list
experience Tim shaddock set sail from La
Paz Mexico back in May It was supposed
to be just him and his dog Bella on a 10
meter catamaran it wasn't supposed to
end like this okay
Australia he looks a little bit worse
for wear but he's alive Australia's 9
news has obtained video shot by
shattuck's Rescuers when they found him
last week nearly 2 000 kilometers from
Shore he and Bella survived for two
months on rainwater and raw fish I've
been through a very difficult ordeal at
Sea
um and I'm just needing rest and good
food because I've been alone at Sea a
long time
stepped onto dry land in Mexico Tuesday
afternoon he was greeted by the founder
of the fishing company that found him
now Shattuck left La Paz May 1st
destination French Polynesia more than 6
000 kilometers away the trouble started
May 14th shattuck's boat was hit by a
storm he lost electronics and started
drifting his catamaran was still sending
a GPS signal until it disappeared May
20th it was a trawler out looking for
tuna that spotted Shattuck and Bella he
was in pretty bad shape he was
dehydrated uh very undernourished oh I'm
feeling all right I uh I'm feeling a lot
better than I was I can tell you now if
Shattuck has a story of survival it's
also one of friendship Bella was a stray
he found in Mexico says there were very
dark times at Sea and he was lucky to
have a great companion yeah that dog is
something else you know I'm a bit biased
but yeah sharik says he still loves the
ocean but asked if he'd be headed back
out soon he had a two-word answer
probably not
Mike Armstrong Global News
and I guess that Bella probably feels
the exact same way that's global
national for this Tuesday night I'm far
enough sir on behalf of our whole crew I
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your Canada is this field of lupins and
Goose Cove near Trinity Newfoundland and
Labrador we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
[Music]